it's a privilege to be online at chatham
house to follow such distinguished
lawyers philip sands depo acandy
and soon to hear mikola nanowski
and can i start by saying i'm in or of
the bravery shown by him and the foreign
minister of ukraine dimitro kulebi
and his government
courage winston churchill once said is
the greatest quality of all because upon
it all else depends
and i want also to acknowledge the
selfless courage of the people of
ukraine president putin's army may
capture ukrainian territory in people's
homes but he will never capture
ukrainian hearts and minds
already far too many lives have been
destroyed but ukraine's resolve is
indestructible hearts are being broken
every hour of the day
but the unity of ukraine is unbreakable
but the people of ukraine now need us to
confront the enormity of the challenge
that president putin's actions pose to
them and the very existence of the
post-1990 international order
he has sought to overturn the rule of
law by the use of force he seeks to
replace the principle of
self-determination with a new form of
imperialism based on a warped reading of
history in his attempt to redraw the map
of europe he seeks to re-divide east and
west
if we were to acquiesce in any way none
of us could ever take freedom for
granted ever again or be sure that
democracy or peace would triumph over
totalitarianism
for all these reasons and because of the
scale of the suffering now imposed on
the people of ukraine
i believe that most people would agree
that this act of aggression by russia
deplored in the strongest terms this
week by the un general assembly
cannot go uninvestigated unprosecuted
and unpunished
but there is as we have heard a serious
gap in international law
since russia is not a party to the
statue of the international criminal
court
then this crime of aggression cannot as
things stand be investigated by the
prosecutor
so even as we encourage carrying can qc
in the international criminal court to
investigate crimes against humanity
genocide and war crimes that may include
the targeting of civilians the use of
vacuum bonds and the threat of nuclear
terror we must also address russia's
responsibility for aggression
crimes against peace starting and
continuing the war with no ceasefire
without safe passage on humanitarian
grounds
doing so will complement the work of the
european court of human rights in
addressing violations of human rights
and the request by ukraine for the
international court of justice to
intervene on its behalf
so i'm here today to support the case my
legal friends have so eloquently set out
and the document documentation for which
i have sent to governments across europe
but most of all i'm here to support the
government of ukraine which is today
calling on the international community
to create a special tribunal to
investigate the specific crime of
aggression one for which mr putin and
his closest military political
intelligence and financial collaborators
may be found to be individually liable
having waged a war that is no
conceivable legal justification as it is
not in self-defense and is contrary to
the charge of the united nations
the special tribunal should be
constituted on the same principles that
guided what we have heard today the
allied powers in 1942 when from in
london they insisted in their statement
punishment for war crimes
that i quote war crimes should not be
left unpunished it was a statement that
led as we've heard to the international
military tribunal which led to the
trials at nuremberg
a tribunal was necessary as the 1942
declaration said to satisfy the sense of
justice of the civilized world
they wanted and i quote again to secure
the punishment through the channel of
organized justice of those guilty or
responsible for these crimes
the special tribunal for the punishment
of the crime of aggression against
ukraine can be set up with speed
and i want to call on all the countries
of europe to agree to grant jurisdiction
to the dedicated tribunal giving it the
power to investigate the principal
perpetrators of the crime of aggression
and all those who are complicit in its
commission including those who provided
finance
now the cost of war is to be counted not
only in tanks destroyed missiles fired
and bullets discharged but in the
desperate cry of wounded children the
anguish of bereaved mothers and fathers
and the tears and suffering of the
innocent
we owe it to the people of ukraine to
act now and show them that never again
will the crime of aggression go
unpunished we ought to the coming
generation to prevent the unmooring of
the international system from its
familiar anchors diplomacy the rule of
law and the willingness to work together
through international institutions
and the need is urgent as we speak
russia are surrounding ukraine's cities
tightening their grip and by their
bombing threatening to create a desert
and call it peace
yes sadly buildings are being raised to
the ground
but not the spirit of the ukrainian
people and by acting in solidarity with
them we will signal our resolve that
lawless aggression will not be tolerated
anywhere on european soil or elsewhere
and that by leaving no stun unturned and
bringing to an end this evil we ensure
that those who who've unleashed the
horrors are subject to personal
accountability under the criminal law
all those hoping for peace not only in
ukraine but across europe cry out for
justice